i
[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france en 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña catalina
loboguerrero ella es periodista
colombiana con una amplia trayectoria
profesional trabajó como corresponsal en
venezuela durante un periodo clave para
este país desde el año 2012 y 2015 y en
su libro cuya portada vamos a ver ahora
en pantalla titulado los restos de la
revolución crónica desde las entrañas de
una venezuela herida nos invita a
recorrer que sucedió durante esos años
en esta nación y también viaja al pasado
en un exhaustivo retrato social político
y cultural de venezuela catalina
loboguerrero muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
hola santiago gracias a ustedes en trans
34 por la invitación no gracias a usted
por supuesto catalina como decía no en
esta presentación de la entrevista usted
llegó a venezuela en un momento clave
para el país no precisamente poco antes
de la muerte de hugo chávez en su libro
de hecho nos da una mirada muy acabada
una visión muy acabada sobre la
transición de poder tras la muerte de
hugo chávez aquel 5 de marzo de 2013
marcó un quiebre de verdad que cambios
fundamentales vio usted que comenzaron
con la muerte de chávez
bueno el libro justamente arranca con
ese día y el momento de su muerte que
fue un momento muy extraño para todos
los venezolanos hugo chávez varias veces
dijo él causó yo y bueno tras su muerte
empezó un caos que lentamente
ha ido empeorando y empeora sobre todo
con nicolás maduro pero que ya venía de
antes hay una transformación profunda en
varios de los aspectos de la vida
venezolana la justicia las fuerzas
militares por supuesto la economía
petrolera que se traduce en una escasez
y una crisis también en el derrumbe del
sistema de salud pública por ejemplo y
también otro tipo de aspectos como la
libertad de expresión y la manera de
operar del periodismo y los medios de
comunicación por mencionar algunos que
aparecen en el libro ahora quisiera a
brotarle porque es un libro es una
investigación sumamente exhaustiva como
decía usted hace un recorrido que tiene
eje en lo que sería la comprensión de lo
que pasó durante todos esos años no
obstante es quizás inevitable no en un
contexto tan particular como el que se
vivía en venezuela por aquellos años
dejar de ver como usted misma estaba
atravesada por todo lo que vivía lo que
veía eso es un aspecto muy interesante
de leer en su libro como periodista
es difícil lograr esa distancia con los
hechos que estaba viviendo con la gente
que había en las calles en esas jornadas
que usted describe de una manera muy
gráfica
mira si hablan mucho de la necesidad de
mantener una distancia desde el
periodismo para los que somos además
corresponsables extranjeros y yo te voy
a ser muy sincera yo no no tuve esa
distancia al contrario yo siento que me
sumergí en las entrañas de un país y por
supuesto todo lo que afectaba a los
venezolanos de alguna manera me afectaba
a mí también
porque yo escribo ese libro como
periodista pero también como residente
no
yo utilizaba el transporte público y no
me movía digamos tampoco como con
píxeles especializados comida en las
mismas areperas donde comían los
venezolanos iba a los mismos
supermercados o pequeñas tiendas de los
barrios las fruterías entonces mis
conversaciones cotidianas también eran
las conversaciones cotidianas que en
esos espacios y en esos lugares podían
darse o tener lugar también como
cualquier otro venezolano y yo escribo
desde esa condición desde corresponsable
extranjera pero también residente de un
país que que también me abrió las
puertas y en el que siempre me sentí muy
bienvenida entonces a veces sentía como
que yo me había ido bien bendición al
venezolanas lizando también
y me sentía muy parte del lugar y por
eso fue también difícil a veces y por
eso también tuve que salirme ya después
del país y me tomé varios años y me tomé
una distancia prudente de tiempo y me
aleje también espacialmente para poder
escribir este libro
voy a pasar luego catalina a ese momento
en el que bueno deja venezuela y toma
esa distancia a la que hacía referencia
pero quisiera abordar ahora otro tema
muy interesante de su libro porque de
alguna manera se aproxima a cierto
aspecto de lo que sería por samán o de
alguna manera la psicología de la
sociedad venezolana con la muerte de
chávez comenzó una suerte de culto a su
figura usted describe muy bien esto en
su libro y habla también de cierta
necesidad del pueblo venezolano de creer
en algo o en alguien a que apunta a
usted con esa necesidad sería algo
cultural algo digo vinculado a la
identidad oa la idiosincrasia de los
venezolanos o tenía que ver con esa
coyuntura en particular que se vivía por
aquel entonces
bueno yo creo que la necesidad de creer
en algo o en alguien sucede
especialmente cuando hay una crisis y no
solamente pasa en venezuela en otros
países también cuando surgen estas
figuras carismáticas populistas
un pico de oro como les llaman en
venezuela a quienes tienen también una
habilidad de un talento para hablar muy
bien y prometen muchas cosas y que todo
va a estar mejor y que el futuro digamos
será distinto pues mucha gente se aferra
a este tipo de discursos y a esa
posibilidad encarnada no en estas
figuras pero lo que me pareció a mí muy
interesante es que ese culto heroico
está presente en venezuela en la
idiosincrasia venezolana en esa
necesidad de tener como estas grandes
figuras referentes y acordémonos que
simón bolívar en libertad
y el padre de la patria pues es una
figura de la que también se le rinde
culto en venezuela antes que a chávez y
para mí fue fascinante también
aproximarme un poco a la historia y ver
como otros caudillos militares también
unían habían utilizado este culto
heroico y ese culto a bolívar que chávez
resucita no con propósitos políticos y
con fines de unir también a una nación
entonces eso sí es muy particular y hay
una religión una creencia en venezuela
que es eso si es de allí que rinde culto
también a los libertadores y a los
héroes de la independencia en el culto
de maría lionza tiene unas cortes dentro
de esas cortes están el culto a los
libertadores y al morir chávez yo empecé
a ver en los almacenes de la avenida
amara baralt que es una avenida en el
centro de caracas en donde hay una
cantidad de tiendas esotéricas y de
artículos religiosos y en donde la gente
compraba también las figuritas de culto
para sus altares no en las casas que
estaban ya empezando a vender belones y
algunas figuras de yeso incluso con la
imagen de hugo chávez yo me hago la
pregunta sin si él no iba a entrar ya
entonces a ese panteón de héroes a los
cuales él rinde culto en la religión de
maría lionza que tenía se asignó esta
referencia precisamente a la historia no
ya está eso a esto apuntaba mi próxima
pregunta porque tu libro tiene toda una
cronología de los
da muchísimo contexto base hacia el
pasado para comprender este presente de
un país es tan complejo no pero no
responde a una necesidad de una
comprensión mucho más acabada de los
hechos actuales y recientes verdad es
necesario echar más luz no sobre la
historia de venezuela a veces pareciera
que en la historia de este país comenzó
con chávez
para mí fue súper necesario echar la
película hacia atrás pero también porque
el mismo gobierno venezolano y la misma
narrativa chavista y de la revolución
utilizaba la historia permanentemente
como una muleta en la cual apoyarse y en
la cual podía justificar algunas
decisiones que eran fundamentales en el
presente y hacia el futuro no entonces
cuando tú hablas de una revolución
en su primer momento se llama
bolivariana antes no tenía el apellido
de socialista la etiqueta socialista
vino después
antes que todo era bolivariano chávez
prometió digamos terminar un proyecto
histórico que había quedado inconcluso
entonces pues es necesario empezar a
meterse un poquito hacia atrás y tratar
de entender también como la historia es
manipulada y presentada por otro tipo de
fines políticos en el presente
catalina la voy a citar ahora algo que
usted dice en su libro la venezuela que
conocí sigue alojada en mi memoria cuál
es esa venezuela cómo es
pues es una escuela que en algún momento
dado yo pensé quedarme porque siempre
como te dije antes me sentí muy
bienvenida es una venezuela que era muy
abierta a los inmigrantes de hecho
durante todo el siglo 20 acogió a una
cantidad de personas que venían de
países del conocido como argentina chile
uruguay que tenían sus dictaduras
algunos brasileños también las
dictaduras caribeñas de derecha y luego
de izquierda también entonces
y hubo también muchos refugiados allí
después de la segunda guerra mundial
italianos españoles de la guerra civil
no portugueses luego vinieron
inmigrantes de otros países con la
revolución pero era una yo vivía en
caracas y caracas era una ciudad abierta
donde se podía conversar donde se podía
intercambiar ideas
una ciudad muy agradable verde
lamentablemente queda atravesada también
por esta puja política que va
transformando también esa apertura y esa
posibilidad de tener un intercambio sin
tantas prevenciones si los venezolanos
quedan atrapados un poco al lado y lado
de lo que yo hablo no que es una grieta
o era chavista o eras anti chavista y la
posibilidad de los matices se empieza a
borrar lamentablemente
eso es lo que se puede ver una profunda
grieta social catalina logo guerrero se
nos ha llegado al final de esta
entrevista se ha pasado muy rápida le
agradezco muchísimo su tiempo con
france24 ha sido un placer dialogar con
usted
santiago un placer dialogar contigo y un
saludo a todos los que están viendo el
programa no gracias a ustedes una vez
más hacia nuestra audiencia como siempre
le invitamos a continuar informándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
y